auch hebammen haben es in der korona
zeit besonders schwer zara shabani
arbeitet in münchen bis zu 16 stunden am
tag um all ihre frauen zu versorgen
ich bin mit ihm sind schon sehr müde und
erschöpft und von emotionen her
als wäre das nicht genug muss sie sich
auch noch sorgen ums geld machen
die versicherungen für freiberufliche
hebammen sind für sie kaum zu bezahlen
für hausbesuche braucht sie ein auto
auch das ist teuer
tara shabani gehört in diesen corona
zeiten zu unseren helden des alltags und
bild möchte ihr jetzt das osterfest
verschönern und deswegen haben wir eine
kleine unschöne überraschung für
[Musik]
liebe sarah wir haben für dich
ein auto du bekommst ein renault zoe von
uns ein elektroauto damit du auch damit
auch zu deinem haus besuchen fahren kann
[Musik]
dankeschön
ich hatte eine uraltes autoren kann neue
der note sehr gut gebrauchen von meinem
haus besuch in vielen dank meines segen
hat der und mensch lange freuen sich
bestimmt auch die länder
wo sagt herzlichen glückwunsch
wohlverdient vielen dank für den tollen
einsatz und wir sind uns relativ sicher
dass du uns und jetzt gerade zu schauen
wir haben alles richtig tolles gewonnen
genau wir haben gedacht wir müssen sie
einfach mal ganz genau zeigen wie dieses
auto das du gewonnen hast aussieht was
das so alles kann und alles hat
vielleicht schauen wir mal was macht das
stellt das auto fuhr und das ist ihr
neuer wagen der neue renault zoe 100%
fahrspaß für 100% elektromobilität und
das ganz ohne geräusche dafür aber eine
reichweite bis zu 395 kilometer mit nur
einer batterieladung und mit sechs
dieser autos wollen wir uns bei ihnen
unseren corona helden für ihre arbeit
bedanken so ist es herzlichen dank nicht
schlecht absoluter sehr sehr gutes auto
und nicht dass sich der einzige auto ist
werden insgesamt renova gibt insgesamt
sechs autos davon ja ja und gewinn da
stehen auch schon fest richter anderem
yvonne mitte märz wird das 900 seelen
dorf neustadt in thüringen abgeriegelt
niemand darf rein oder raus alle stehen
unter quarantäne
doch eine frau ist trotzdem unermüdlich
im einsatz
sie sind mitarbeiterin eines
pflegedienstes die einzige pflegekraft
in diesem abgeriegelten ort die dort
lebt und sie kümmern sich jetzt alleine
ganz alleine um die pflegebedürftigen
dorfbewohner die von carl versorgt ohne
zu zögern weiter ihre pflegebedürftigen
patienten
sie ist der engel von neustadt guten kvk
wir möchten ihnen im namen kunden danke
sagen
als dank für ihren einsatz bekommt sie
nun einen neuen renault sowie im wert
von 23.000 euro und wenn ich ruhig mit
ihrem neuen auto wird die bundes in
zukunft ein bisschen leichter haben
menschen in not zu helfen
[Musik]